back in 2008
someone suggested i watch the secret i
had watched it and it was spring of 2008
and then i don't know if it was the
exact next race it might have been
because i i was a race car driver yes um
and the next race was my race in japan
that i finally won in indycar
and i always connect the dots between
watching the secret right and winning in
japan right right and so thank you so
much oh gosh you did it
thank you you're the one who did it 2006
until now
unrecognizable life for me i have to say
compared to prior to 2006
when i was just
totally asleep to everything
so
it's really good to be conscious
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
i am so excited about the guest on the
show today
her name is rhonda byrne
she you may remember it she created and
produced the secret like this was
revolutionary i watched the secret in
2008 and then i went and won in japan
but i always connect the two and i think
she really
brought in
the idea that you can manifest your life
the law of attraction
thoughts matter thoughts become things
energy
she really i feel
was for at least for me she was the
first one to bring this into mainstream
she's also an author she's written a
bunch of books she has a new one that
just came out called the greatest secret
our conversation was all about her
journey how she had these epiphanies her
stories of transformation and
you know she's constantly see she's
really like a i think she's maybe
reached a point now where she's not so
constantly seeking and she's being much
more and uh it was just a fascinating
conversation full of so many stories and
just like your jaw will be on the ground
when you hear some of them and just how
magical the universe is and that it is
so in your favor and it is not against
you and she gives so many good tips on
how to live in that flow so that you can
benefit from the
infinite potentiality that the universe
has to offer us versus what our limited
minds have only seen or experienced so
um i hope that you found this just as
fascinating as i did and that you take
so much away from it and are able to
apply it in your life and truly live the
life that you want to so enjoy the
episode i tend to just do
one thing
so you're it you're the star today star
of the day so my honor i like let me go
back in time for a little bit of
background so you can understand how
long i've been aware of you
um
back in 2008
someone suggested i watched the secret
and i was like
okay
and
what year did it come out
206 okay 2006. so
so it had been around for a bit but i
had watched it and it was spring of 2008
and then i don't know if it was the
exact next race it might have been
because i i was a race car driver yes
yes um
and the next race was my race in japan
that i finally won in indycar
and i always connect the dots between
watching the secret right and winning in
japan right right and so thank you so
much oh gosh you did it
you're the one who did it so
yeah it's been 2006 until now
unrecognizable life for me i have to say
compared to prior to 2006
when i was just
totally asleep to everything
so
it's really good to be conscious it is
but it's a journey at the same time oh
it's a journey
yeah it is but it's a wonderful journey
yeah it's like you talk to anybody
that's on the journey of waking up of
consciousness of healing of any of those
things and
you know it can there can be really
rough periods where you have to face a
lot of things and look at yourself and
the things that you've denied or the
things that you've not nurtured or
cultivated whether it be inner child or
whether it be
relationships or the way you show up and
how you feel about them and how you
project but at the end of the day it's
always a rise in frequency and it's
always a greater
a greater existence on a daily basis
like your baseline changes it does
and you you just become i wouldn't have
been able to recognize this i don't
think going back to 2006 but
you
you become
freer
so my first step to freedom was
definitely the realization of the secret
and that we
can create our lives whichever way we
want to create them that was just the
most massive
breath of freedom
um and and was incredible and so my life
completely changed from that uh 360 360
in every single area but then
i always felt well if if this is the
case
then there must be more that i don't
know and so i just became a crazy crazy
sincere seeker i just read every book
that was going i went back through time
i was going through all of the
traditions and the religions i just
could not get enough
and um and i was doing it 24 7 and i
could do it 24 7. because it was really
my work so
so it was amazing to be able to do it
just so blessed well that's an example
of doing something endlessly
and getting you're like so energized for
it and insatiable for it because it's so
your purpose
i was not the least bit tired i had to
force myself to go to sleep i couldn't
wait to wake up in the morning and so i
could keep going and doing more and more
and more and i had so many realizations
over those years
one after the other after the other
after the other aha moments that
completely changed the way that i saw
the world and the way that i saw myself
and it just kept continuing that way and
so the more realizations that i had the
more that i could see the way things
really are the happier i became the
happier i became happier happier happy
happier and
less able to be disturbed by
people and events
well what was the first story what is
the first story that you wrote it was
like hit being
hit with a truck or or enlightened
probably not in in a negative way but
what was that first thing that that aha
that epiphany that happened that made
you realize that got you into
the path that led to the secret
it was a particular evening
and i had had a really really rough year
that year my father had died suddenly
and i was making six movies about
unsolved murders so it's a really really
rough subject i had a production company
and so everything that could go wrong
went wrong that year until i reached
september the 9th and i had two phone
calls in a row
and like it was time so beautifully when
i look back was incredible because the
first phone call absolutely brought me
to my knees and that was my accountant
saying you're going to
you're going to be broke in 30 days
you've gone two million dollars over
budget on the movies and i still had one
and a half to deliver
um and i had a had a director and we've
gone over budget and then i hung up the
phone and as i had the phone it rang
again it was my mother and he was in a
really bad way so those two phone calls
absolutely brought me to my knees
because i
didn't feel that i could solve either
problem like i was so good at fixing
things but these two things my mother
was grief-stricken
because my father had died earlier in
the year and so these two things i could
not solve and and so i just collapsed in
despair
and that moment of collapsing in despair
was the moment where my life would
change forever
because my daughter
my adult daughter saw me
and just walked out and handed me this
book which was from 1910 and said read
this little help
and i mean
i've asked her since why did you give me
that book
and she's like i don't know you know she
just didn't know she was just and the
way that she gave it to me was almost
kind of
um robot like do you know like just uh
handing it what's even weirder
is that with with the sky falling in
after the two phone calls is that
i read the book
right you made time for the book i just
sat down right there and then and i and
i opened it up and i started reading and
all my tears were hitting the pages the
ink was running and 90 minutes later i'd
finished reading it and oh my gosh
my life had completely changed i knew
things
that were
not in that book
i just re had the biggest biggest
realization of course the book was the
trigger and the book is called the
science of getting rich by wallace
wattles and it's available for free on
our website
if anybody wants to download it the
sacred tv
but that book
i just saw so much in that book and that
set me off on a search from that book
onward i went back into time
searching for this information that i
absolutely knew was the truth that we
created our life and i just went back
right back through history actually way
back to the emerald tablet and i didn't
tell anybody what i'd found i just
continued to research and it's like what
you were talking about
i just there was something rushing
through me that
just took me i i i barely slept
and then it was almost like like i would
pick up a book and i would start to read
it and i would read that book and i then
i would look at the time and think oh
it's really late and it was five minutes
from when i last looked at it like it
was like time stopped and it was like
time became really malleable for me
and so wow yeah well that's a reality
time is space this is the dimension you
like you like were in a different
reality a different dimension where time
wasn't relevant
time wasn't and and so i just what i
accomplished in three months was crazy
and in in terms of reading and research
and then
in january this was in september and oh
i mean mind you i drove to my mother
straight away the next morning and i
told her everything i discovered so i
got her all set
and and a whole new world had opened up
for her and then i went back continue
with the research and in january
of 2005 i walked into my team and i said
we are going to make
um and i it wasn't a documentary at that
stage or a movie or i didn't know what
it was we're going to make something
that will change the world
and they thought i was mad
well i said this isn't there saying
about like it takes someone with like
say someone crazy or mad to change the
world they have to actually believe it's
possible
totally which is which is the secret you
know
and so that was how
it all began and uh and you know we were
really practicing the secret while
making the secret and so we became very
very aware
you know i was very aware of signs of
messages of hearing things of being
guided but everything we needed was just
put in front of us absolutely everything
what were the signs like what were the
things happening that made you go green
light green light green light here we go
okay so one example is we came to the
united states to film teachers
we had no teachers lined up to film
absolutely none whatsoever
we
we could reach teachers so easily like
it was just crazy
and they would all just say yes but one
of the teachers was jack canfield and he
was in aspen at the time and so we went
to us but he agree he agreed to be
filmed and he asked me to do a
presentation when i got there and we'd
made a big trailer and
there was something like
60 teachers
in that room
that i presented and when i presented
the secret and what it was going to do
and jack said
who wants to be in this documentary
put your hand up
all put their hand up and so in addition
to that we had been trying to get in
touch with bob proctor
um through his people
and
and then when we were in aspen finally
my researcher was in touch with his
personal assistant and she said look
where are you at the moment and
and it was my sister actually who was
helping me and she's
and she said we're in aspen
and and
um bob's assistant said oh
my god he's in aspen he said that's food
yeah he said
and so the moment she told him he came
over to us in 30 minutes because he knew
it was meant to be and they all knew
like
they all just knew that something
incredible was happening and even the
way we released it like i'd had in my
mind
that because i had a production company
that was uh that made content for
television and so in my mind this was
going to be released on television
through networks around the world in a
24-hour period that was the way that i
saw it that it would be released
globally basically at the same time and
so i had all of these networks all
interested and then there was this
extraordinary thing they all just
dropped out
like one by one by one by one
and so
i knew
that this was not the way it was meant
to go
and so i just opened myself to the
possibility of it going out differently
we spoke to some film companies they
just wanted to buy it and
you know buy it out completely and i i
wouldn't do it and and so then
eventually what happened was um i saw
an advertisement on the internet you've
kind of got to imagine a time that was
so different from now but i saw this
british airways commercial on the
internet
and i was like that's it
we released this on the internet now
nothing no movie had ever been released
on the internet and i called i called to
see our my ceo and i said we'll release
it on the internet it will be go around
the world in 24 hours and he said oh
that might be one way that you release
it but you can't release it that way
entirely well do you know my ceo
happened to be
happened to be
amazing at technology he worked with a
company that just happened to be two
streets from my office who who put out
that british airways commercial in
melbourne in australia
and
he worked with them and created the
technology for the secret to go out
um on the internet so it was the first
first um film that had gone out on the
internet and within one hour of it going
out i knew that was it like i just
sat back and it didn't matter what
happened from there it was out in the
world and that was all that mattered to
me but what's special about that story
is that it's really easy
to
see the signs when it's positive
but it's hard i feel like to accept the
signs when they're negative
and so
as you were being
you know
left to dry with the networks about
putting it out on television
i think that that that to me is the most
was a striking part about the story is
that you go okay
well we're not going to do it that way
but that that that might be the point
and i'm curious how you got to the point
where you could re where you allowed the
signs both positive and negative to
equal in
um volume because that would be the
point in time where you know my older
self where i'm so used to forcing i
would push through and i'd be like well
let's call somebody else and let's
figure this out give me the phone send
me an e i'll send an email let's go
there and i would push through it and
that's like so can you explain how you
got to that point and how you then and
how you also stay in alignment so that
you don't force things that aren't
because there's a you have to put effort
into things but there's a difference
between effort and forcing to the point
where you're getting enough signs that
it's kind of turning into a wall yeah
that's true
um
i just knew from the secret
that everything was happening for me
and that also meant that if there was a
block
don't push against it if there is a
block
and that is something doesn't come
through straight away stop
stop and for example like i'll give you
an example
we filmed
a teacher
that um
i wasn't
100
sure about when we filmed that teacher
but there was a technical problem all
through it and that was unusable footage
you know
and so i knew
i knew that that person was not meant to
be in it then there were other teachers
that we contacted who didn't respond
really well known ones for example who
didn't respond
and um and i knew they were not meant to
be in it i knew
i knew that whatever we needed would be
given to us and if there was a block i
would not push against it and as you say
actually it's very different from what i
used to be because i used to be oh i
will fix this i will do this i will get
it done and and look for another way but
instead i would stop and i would wait to
see what was going to be shown to me and
this is living the secret this is really
really living it where you understand
that this is a friendly universe and it
is doing everything for you it is
conspiring for you in every single area
and with the making of the secret was
the most spectacular thing i have ever
seen in my entire life because
everything was done for us and and even
down to the point where
um i remember we would be editing and we
we were like
16 hours in the edit suite editing all
of this masses of footage
and and then suddenly the system would
um rainbow ball you know in other words
it was it was it was going to crash and
uh and i would just say to the editor
get up walk away
because we were causing that rainbow
ball you know we were like this you know
we were too tense in editing trying to
push against time not relaxed
and so the equipment was responding to
our
pushing you know and that's in secret
too because it's it's it's if you are
like i'm gonna be late i'm gonna be late
and you're rushing and rushing then that
energy will cause a car to be in front
of you slow slow down you know this will
happen the the train line gates will
come down everything will happen but if
you just let it go and you relax which
is what i experimented with if i was
running late for somewhere i would do
the exact opposite so i would just let
go i would stop rushing and then
everything would just line up and i
would be there on time
that happens to me sometimes
when i cause i say sometimes because
my aggressive driving nature gets the
best of me most of the time
but when i'm like
you know what just relax
instead of speeding up to get by that
car i'll just fall in line and wait and
then all of a sudden almost all every
time the car will move over
it will turn and i'm like why don't i do
that more often that works so easy like
what's our cultural problem what's our
what's our cultural problem and then
what is the solution to
getting into that mode because
and trusting that i think it's i think
it's not even about trusting it as much
because i think once you see it you see
it but how do we keep ourselves in that
mode because even though i can repeat
these kinds of things to you in
awareness
there's something in my brain i don't
know if i'm just too high beta state at
times and
whatever it is but
how do we get down to that state where
we are allowing and flowing
and one with the universe instead of
constantly pushing against it it's
really is i didn't realize what i was
doing when i was doing it these days i
understand what i was doing and and and
i eat
i have practiced
um very deliberately to surrender and
let go
and and so that is what i do
constantly
constantly
back then
i don't know how i did it but i would
just cut i just had such faith in the
universe because that was the way that i
described it
and i i had set the biggest intentions
for the secret and i just knew that
everything would happen for us so we're
very much in the flow and if we were not
we stopped
and we were and we just walked away
until we felt good we came back and and
would continue working when we felt good
when i didn't feel good i would not
answer the phone i would not open my
computer i would not do any of those
things because if you're on a really bad
frequency and you open up your computer
in comes a whole lot of problems it's so
good on the same frequency so i just
wouldn't open my computer and i wouldn't
answer my phone until i would until i
could feel a whole lot better and so
that was very deliberate way that i did
it then these days
is very different i don't have such a
personal
attachment to i am doing this
you know with the universe the universe
is doing this for me
i am the universe
kind of one
with the universe
and so
i
i am just in the complete
state of
allowing surrendering letting go
because
we are the ones that need to get out of
the way
because everything that will be given to
us that will happen for us
is way beyond what we could even imagine
for ourselves
i could imagine it i'd be striving for
it but when you let go
of your own idea of how something could
go you're now open to the quantum field
of all potentiality that goes
far far beyond what our imagination has
even
conceived experience seen or caught a
glimpse of exactly exactly because all
we can imagine is the mind and the mind
is tends to be a recycling machine and
then as you say in the quantum area or
beyond the mind is every single
possibility unlimited possibilities and
so
yeah i just keep surrendering
to all of that and the less
we put ourselves in the way with our
fixed ideas and opinions and all of
those things you know
and we we kind of get those out of the
way the more magnificent our life
becomes
absolutely magnificent
i've found that the
human experience is challenging because
it takes experiences
patterns relationships friendships
family it takes all these dynamics that
push on us to see ourself
and it's hard to see yourself and so
how did you get to that point where you
could kind of release and surrender and
get to that point
did you have
did you process anything about childhood
was there anything about your upbringing
something about family something about
your own patterning or were you able to
just
not have to go there and access
this potentiality
with
the simple awareness of the secret
right i saw
um in 216 i
had a revelation of who we really are
and so
that is what really changed everything
um
and
and even i think in secret i would refer
we are the infinite being you know would
say it in the sacred and and
i
definitely
believed that felt that um knew that
it's just that in 216 i had the
experience of it
and so i realized then
that the person is absolutely the
smallest smallest tiniest part of us
and
so basically i just spent my time
releasing
any
negativity that arises any
memories
that arise because i know that
any negativity that appears or that that
that somebody else triggers with
negative feelings or negative thoughts
any um
uh any memories appear because they're
ready to be released from our life
that's why they're appearing they're
ready to be free and so i know those
things are inside of us held in our
subconscious mind and when they appear
they're ready to be free so i learned
how to release them
really quickly and
and it it applies to everything
that you
everything negative everything that we
consider negative but i only release the
things that appear
and uh and
if
if a negative feeling comes along like
like agitation or disappointment like i
would get so excited
because it wouldn't mean i could release
it and in the releasing of it once
you've released it all you'll never feel
it again
like there isn't anybody that can
aggravate you in the outside world the
only reason they can aggravate you is
because you have it inside you ready to
be released right which you know very
well so um
so i just kept releasing and releasing
and what i found was the more i released
the happier i got and so then i would
see things like i had beliefs that
didn't serve me and i would just release
the beliefs that didn't serve me and oh
my gosh then that's beautiful and not
overwhelming not at all you know because
yeah in my mind i think oh man get
through all the trauma like he loves
things like you know of ancestral things
like dig in but right like how do i get
to that
the way you're describing it and and
this is i think one of your many gifts
is to put things simply so it can be
comprehended and understood
and is that just when it comes up you
deal with it so of course i'm curious
what was that thing that happened in
2016.
i i um
i had another kind of uh
moment
um i had another moment i had a
circumstance happen with a house that i
was selling and it ended up that i felt
this it fell through really quickly and
um after i'd made all these plans to
kind of move out in a week and
i felt this incredible disappointment in
my body and i was just like how could i
feel
something like this when i always feel
so good i didn't understand it and so
what i what i did was i just decided i
wanted to watch something spiritual i
didn't want this feeling and so i just
wanted to watch something spiritual so
the feeling would go away and
i turned on my computer and conscious tv
and they were interviewing a man called
david bingham who's just an everyday
person
like you and me not a teacher or
anything like that and he talked about
how
he saw the truth and became free
and i was like the truth
and i followed in his footsteps and did
what he did which he listened to a
podcast
and by a man called john wheeler i
listened to that podcast
and you know it's really interesting
because i watched the conscious tv
interview with him several times i
listened to the podcast multiple times
and then i reached out to david to speak
to him and this was over a period of
uh
three or so days and then when i spoke
to david
um
he sort of did an experiment with me
where he showed me
the the
my mind focusing
and what's there if my mind
isn't focusing
what's behind my mind and has been there
the entire time for my whole life
yeah
and it was
i was just
wow
and david said to me you'd already seen
it before we got on the phone and i said
had i really and he and he said yes but
all i know is
those few things and i saw
who
i was from my own experience the
unlimitedness
of who we are
and that there are no boundaries and
and so everything changed again
massively the way i see the world and
it's the second
huge step to freedom
right well it's just our perception
that colors our world
we it's not always nice sometimes we
have things that happen to us we have
patterning from parents patterning from
friends and then growing up an
environment television
we have all kinds of different things
that give us a perception
and again since it's so hard to see
ourselves it's like you have to have
these moments right where you go oh
so what is the letting go process then
so the technique to help release things
and i keep working on it all of the time
because
um
in fact i just said to my daughter i
have to find a simpler way of saying
this
uh i i just want it to be simpler and
i've covered it in my book the greatest
secret but i still
like i'm always looking for simpler
simple and simple ways so
one of the things just to understand so
people can get the feeling
is one of the things that we do
is we resist all the way along in our
life we resist when something happens
that we don't want to happen
and i don't want that we resist and so
we we're kind of um
enjoying like the things we like but the
things we don't like we like pushing
them away including
including people or a comment that
somebody makes we don't like that
comment and it affects us
and so
um and so that's all resistance and
resistance is what causes all the
negative feelings and contractions
inside of us
and so what releasing does is it stops
us from resisting
and so
it
if a
negative subject arises a negative
memory a negative feeling it is because
we have just resisted and so to
counteract that resisting and stop that
resisting we do the opposite to
resisting
and so what we do is like i could say
just like relax but i say welcome it
welcome the feeling welcome the the
memory
welcome the thought
and it's really just that we
we
don't try and fix it we don't try and
change it we don't try and make it go
away we don't try and do anything to it
we just allow it
to be there and in the allowing of it to
be there we stop resisting and it just
the energy
just evaporates and very often you can
feel the energy unwinding in your chest
it's just an automatic cleansing system
in our body the moment we stop resisting
everything unwinds and so
you could just do this if if nothing
appeared you could just be really
relaxed and just
allowing of everything to be just the
way it is right now
and so to be very present as well of
course helps to do that
and then if all the energy that is
trapped just begins to unwind and be
released
and why we don't need to go through
picking one trauma one memory after
another
is because
that many of them attach like a train
with carriages and so we can get one and
it just pulls the whole train
of carriages
at the same time
and takes a whole takes a whole lot of
memories with it and so we don't need to
go through anything one by one
we just need to see the ones that appear
the ones that are triggered the
you know the feelings that uh that are
triggered by an outside event i know
that you talked about mirroring and and
that's what's so beautiful is that i
mean i can use the universe as an
example we'll use people circumstances
and events
it will use all of those things to show
us
what needs to be released
you know and and so it's just
everything that happens to us is the
most beautiful gift steeped in love and
designed for us to be happier and to be
free
and so that's how i release now you get
re you get that good at it
that
i don't even know how i do it now i just
kind of you feel a relief you just uh
you just kind of welcome
and and just sort of
sort of sink and you immediately feel a
sense of relief through your body and
you just feel this thing dissipate and
disappear and it's amazing you can have
a really strong emotion
and it will just evaporate
as the best feeling in the whole world
do you think that they're yes it sounds
magical this sounds like floating
through life
but do you think that they're yeah
2016 was when you were able to
sort of sense and feel this
i'm going to call it from my perspective
what would be like the observer
you can access the observer of your
thoughts because we aren't our thoughts
right so we're there's something that's
able to recognize that we're having
thoughts
so we can't be our thoughts because we
know we're having thoughts
and so do you feel like this
transitioned when you felt that more
observer perspective that instead of
things happening to you and being in the
moment you're actually like almost
looking from above feeling from above
and allowing this sort of exchange of
energy to come and release and go
because you're not in it and you're not
grasping onto either the memory
something you wanted or
identifying with pain or some sort of
level of victimization
or something you want like it's more
observer mode
oh it's definitely what it is this is
definitely what it is you become the
observer rather than
the observer of the person
you know and the observer of yourself
and so you create this kind of gap so
everything's not as personal you know
and and you just discover incredible
things you know you allow other things
to be released because and i think you
said it in your 20 i watched your 20 uh
things that you realized over
2020. i watched the lessons this morning
and um and and and
yeah one of the things for sure is that
you
um
you just begin to
you begin to see everything
really really clearly and you're not so
attached and you're not so identified
because when we identify with those
things then we really feel the pain of
those things and and and as you said
actually nothing's personal feel it's so
personal
everything's that's not it's not all
personal and so when you're the observer
then you can have some relief from it
not being personal at all
yeah so do you feel like this also
affects the way you see other people
meaning instead of seeing them do
something to you you actually see their
pain
and their
patterning perhaps as opposed to
why'd you do that to me like you can
actually see their
light instead of the projection
exactly and and you can see that's where
they are
that and and and you don't have this if
somebody asked for your help you would
just do anything and give it you're not
overcome with this well i need to fix
everybody you know because everybody is
just in the perfect place where they are
they're they're exactly where they're
meant to be
somebody wrote in to me and said how do
i get back on track and i said well
you're never off track
ever
explain that what does that mean for
them when you're like don't worry about
it everything is perfect you're right on
track what is that what should that be
telling them
well because immediately you look for
first of all immediately you let go of
resistance so the mind is saying oh
you're off track you're off track and
then you believe it and then you then
you create it and then you feel like
you're off track and i'm saying but
you're actually on track you're
perfectly on track now if i could have
had a conversation with the person i
would have said to them
are you the one that's off track or are
you the one who is aware
that you're off track are you the one
that's aware or are you the one that's
off track
and we're always the one that's aware
which is the observer right your
observer and so
and so that kind of frees you up right
away because it stops the mind from kind
of getting you
and having you identify with this
concept that the mind just made up it
just made up this concept you're off
track
we swallowed it hook line and sinker
we're perpetuating it i'm off track i
believe it i'm off track i'm off track
no you're not you're perfectly on track
and and then to look at it in in an even
bigger perspective is that we are always
exactly where we're meant to be
and robert adams used to say everything
is unfolding exactly as it should
and
and
everyone is going to be fine in the end
none of us can be hurt or harmed in the
anonymous we're all eternal
and it's up to everybody to discover
that about themselves
and i can only encourage people and say
it's the greatest journey you will ever
take
um is to find out who you are and to
free yourself it's really really
wonderful but there's you know there's
death of the body sure but there's not
death of the consciousness of who we are
and so we're just here having fun
i'm curious if you feel like
you come into that we come into life as
people with a purpose and a mission
i'm asking that because the the secret
is all about manifesting your life and
asking the universe and sort of
allowing the flow of things so do you
feel like you came in with a purpose in
some of your stories you talk about this
knowing that you have and you know
there's like it's almost like it's like
this tiny bit of information that
unlocks this huge vast library of
of of content and knowing and so i
wonder where you stand on that do you
feel like you came in with a mission um
i do
and definitely
the secret was a part of that for sure i
mean i looked back
on my life and i just saw how
i had just been shaped all the way along
for that moment
i just felt that my entire life was
was heading toward that moment even to
the point of
to give you an example
i worked in
television and i worked in news and um
and so i was very aware of news
manipulating stories the way that they
wanted to manipulate them and so when
the secret became massive i had every
show and organization
wanting to interview me newspapers and
everything and
i knew because of my experience with
news that if i succumbed to all of that
and did all of that there would just be
this thing of building you up and then
tearing you down
and i knew not to do it now i would
never have known that had i not had the
experience in news and so i was very
careful about what i did i did oprah
because i knew
that oprah lived her life you know this
that this way and so i was very
particular about what i did the other
thing was
was that i wanted to make sure that the
message was
the star and not
um not me
and
i'm i'm happy to be there to say this is
what i discovered and i had to share it
with the world and i really did i i just
i couldn't have lived
without sharing this it just it was a
force that was coming through me so
i definitely know that the journey that
i ended up on was the journey that i was
meant to be on however i want to say
that it's the same for everybody it's
just that it's so more easily marked
maybe with the secret you know because
it was a big event but with everybody's
lives you know there may be a mother and
she has three children and she does all
of these things of bringing up the
children and the children grow up to be
beautiful human beings
that is
exactly what she was meant to do she is
meant to be the beautiful mother to have
that experience to to shape those beings
her children and so i i i just know that
that's why we're on track in any given
moment even if we're hurting
um
we're still on track
now
but what is our purpose
like
um
and our purpose i'm
absolutely convinced is to find out who
we are
and so i think that's our purpose is to
realize that we're much more than what
we're seeing
and i think that's our ultimate purpose
because when we discover that we're free
when we discover it i don't mean as a
concept or intellectually i mean when we
experience it for ourselves
then we are free and then we find
permanent happiness
and then
we're not afraid of death because we
know we don't die you know so have you
had any
transcendental or very spiritual moments
that showed you a different reality or
showed you
showed you perhaps source
god
higher dimension
have you ever had any of those moments i
have yes i have
um i had
probably the one that had the biggest
impact on me was when i was a child and
i was about 10 or 12 years of age and
i was one of four
girls at that time and we were very
protected by my parents so there wasn't
a lot of socializing
in those times we were just really the
siblings we just played with each other
and but i was
sent away to a school camp and that was
a really big deal for me to be separated
from my family i'd never been separated
from them before
and i was very shy
and so
i we went to this camp and somehow or
another i had developed this really
really bad
what i came to see later on migraine
headache
and i didn't even i was so shy i didn't
even tell
the teachers that i was so sick
and um and i remember we were in these
huts and we all were put to bed and of
course the moment you lay down with the
needling it's even worse than ever right
and i i felt so ill
and but still too afraid to tell anybody
and so i just walked out of the heart i
can't even believe i did this but it was
night and i walked out of the heart
and down the little steps and it this
camp was by the ocean and i stood on
this
um
cliff edge
and i said
in my 12
12 or 10 year old way if there is a god
please take away this headache right now
and
not only did the headache
dissolve
instantly
but the most incredible joy and ecstasy
and love
swept all through me
and i had tears pouring down my face and
there
and
from that moment on i always knew that
god existed
there always and so it wouldn't matter
if the whole world said oh no you know
no such thing
no from my own experience i knew it and
my
the way i the way i i see that god is
very different from the way i saw that
god as a ten-year-old i saw god as
something separate from me right and um
you know that god out there was sort of
talking to the
sky and um
but yeah so that was a really big
experience but i've had many many
spiritual experiences which
like the earlier one that collapsed time
and space and where i'm here but then
i'm there and wait uh did you tell that
story was that the reading one where you
got were you ready
yeah that's the rating one and i've been
in some places and then i'm in another
place and
tell me more about that that sounds like
fun astral travel yes i was with a
teacher and uh and we were 60 miles away
from a city
and um and i asked this teacher a
question
about
you know dimensions and traveling from
one dimension to the next
and um
and he
and he he said close your eyes to all of
us in the car we're traveling on a
freeway we could see the city way in the
distance like 60 or so miles away so we
closed our eyes and next thing there was
this bump
and we opened our eyes and we're in the
driveway uh driveway in the city yeah do
you remember what happened in that time
frame or was there was no time
so was this a shaman was this a sh was
this a shot no no just a teacher he was
a teacher and um
uh and
yeah he just
i think had a really good understanding
of time and space and uh that doesn't
really exist and
yeah so but i had i was really lucky
because we there were five people in the
car and one of them was my daughter as
well so
but what was really amazing about that
experience for me is that
is this
is that
what it had me say was that
nothing is what it appears to be
and when you can have an experience
where what you believed is you know
solid and can't move and when you have
an experience like that
it just you kind of melt and then all of
the fixed ideas you have begin to
collapse
that the things where you're convinced
that that you're walking into a room i
mean quantum physics tells us
you know quantum quantum physics tells
us that when we walk out of a room it
doesn't exist anymore and the room just
appears when we observe it and so i mean
i used to i studied quite a physics and
so i used to try and you know catch the
room coming back into existence
which
hysterical right there's a very high
probability that it is a virtual reality
it definitely is and i remember a
teacher lester levinson saying that
reality is actually very vaporous so
therefore very malleable
now i definitely know when i was
researching the secret that i
i didn't do it deliberately but time
just collapsed
it it just collapsed for me it's just
and i was able to do things in in kind
of no time at all and and it's you can't
explain that
you know that's beyond what we
uh what we see is reality but i would
just say to people
that if if you if you look at quantum
physics everything that you think is
real isn't real anyway yeah even the uh
the doctor who or the sorry the
scientists who discovered
that and i'm not going to say this in
exact scientific terms but basically
when he discovered that we're that
nothing's really real nothing's really
matter it's just energy it's like
it's just it's just energy it's little
little tornadoes little we're just a
little mini tornado we're at this
density where we sort of collect into
this form but when he discovered that he
got up the next day and put his feet
down on the ground and was a afraid he'd
fall through the floor because he
because he knew that that nothing was
actually matter i can actually relate i
can actually understand that i've not
had that experience
but
i can totally understand that is when
you can see
that none of it's really there and i
have had realizations of
oh my gosh
everything
that we experience of the world is all
experienced on the inside we can
actually prove there's an outside like i
would go through all of these
experiments to break down
the very
concrete structure that the mind has
created
so that i could open to the possibility
of seeing the way things really are and
of course the way things really are are
way more beautiful is way more beautiful
than the way the mind has constructed it
way more beautiful what have you um
learned have do you
are you aware of your gifts
like what you're able to do or see
sort of beyond the beyond the normal
any of those kinds of things because i
just get the sense like you have you
know there's sort of like a a clear
cognizant nature to you and you know
where you just know things have you have
you ever have you
found those out um do you know i
i can remember this mentor of mine
um
i i
could see things light and all kinds of
things and or as i remember walk past a
person and said they had this aura
around them i was like wow
this is so cool and i would see light
like somebody would be talking and
and
it was on a really beautiful subject and
i would just see all this light coming
from their hand and and so i just
thought oh this is so cool and and so i
had a mentor at the time who's
who's
um spanish and who's in
the imperative of uh
an order over
an order that helps raise consciousness
and so i was telling him about all of
these experiences that i had like i was
super excited to tell him
and he just sat there kind of
like this
no i impressed and and and he said it's
normal
it's normal
and it was really amazing about that
because
i thought it was like supernatural but
he was telling me it's all natural
and so
anything the ability
to know things and i do know things like
if
if i um
like i know for example there was a
friend of ours and she was rushed to
hospital and she was pregnant and the
baby was um
i think it was she was like 32 weeks and
my daughter came to me and said
can you please give her magic dust um
so that she will be okay with the baby
and and and i said
and i said that little girl is going to
be just fine and i said she's having a
girl right
and my daughter said they don't know
what they're having
and i said oh
it's a girl she's gonna be fine
and poppy was born and she was just fine
and i i just knew that
how did i know that i just knew that but
it's the same for everybody there's
nothing special here at all
it is just
open your mind just open yourself to the
possibility
that things are different from the way
that you think they are
and that they are more beautiful more
magnificent more amazing because people
can be really afraid you know like if
they think oh i don't want to see light
seeing light as good
it's gorgeous there's nothing to be
afraid of and that's also the other
thing my mentor said to me there's
nothing spiritual that can ever harm you
there is nothing to ever be afraid of
yeah
yeah yeah because people are afraid you
know they're afraid of the dark
and uh
uh no nothing nothing spiritual can ever
ever harm us
so um yeah so i always just took that
into my heart i would agree and i would
i i mean i've had some weird mystical
sort of like scary things that have had
oh yeah yeah
but one of them i mean i've had the good
ones the sort of transcendental good
ones but i've also had a few of the bad
ones
and i remember one in particular i was i
was in a hotel
and i was asleep and i woke up to
i woke up i didn't wake up but i awoke
in my dream to
like a silhouette of like a little boy
it was like a black see-through sort of
smoky image of like a little boy
and it ran around the room
and then it started jumped on the bed
and started jumping on the bed and then
i turned over to go to sleep on like
turned over away from the facing side to
the door
and then it laid down in the bed next to
me staring at me
and the only thing that i knew to do at
that point in time even in my sort of
lucid state was to pray and so i just
asked for this to go
for help for angels for all the support
and i fell asleep and i woke up and you
know i had cried in the night so like my
eyes were crusty
and and so things can scare you but
nothing can hurt you
nothing can hurt you no no
nothing at all i mean i can remember my
the ceiling of my bedroom like i would i
would wake up and it would just have all
these like hieroglyphics over it you
know all of these yeah
wow look at that
you know
all of these like symbols egyptian
symbols and everything and that just did
not surprise me because
i had i had traced the secret back to
the ancient mystery schools so
so the fact that all of this appeared on
the ceiling just didn't surprise me at
all
and i just laid there i was like wow
this is gorgeous have you been to egypt
i went to egypt earlier this year
finally i mean i've been called i've
been called to egypt for since i was
like probably 18 or 19 i thought the
oddball place that i wanted to go and so
this was 20 years ago where nobody was
wanting to go to egypt 20 years ago at
least not in my reality yeah and um i
finally ended up going and it was one of
those sort of scenarios it went all went
very quick i was
doing a joe dispenza i was with joe
dispenza in santa barbara and it was
just like a one day little event and
there was about 20 of us and there was a
manifestation
um uh technique showed where we write
down a letter representing what we
wanted to manifest and then reasons why
and then elevated emotions and
connecting with it and so at dinner that
night
a girl turned over and she goes i heard
you're interested in egypt and i said
what
i was like shocked i was like do you
know what i wrote down
and she said no she goes but the girl
next to me said you guys were talking
about egypt earlier she goes there's a
trip in february if you want to go and
so that like all came down
within like two hours after manifesting
it and and the funny thing was is i
really released the timeline on
manifesting it and i thought
i'll i'll i'll focus on this for for the
next couple of years if it takes to
manifest the right trip
and it came about and so we ended up
going in february and it was so
beautiful and it was just you know you
really unders you really get the
perspective the main perspective was
that we don't get it like we don't see
it all we don't know it all we have no
idea how anything was done we're talking
about what's written on the walls we
don't even know how they made the walls
like how they are so perfect how did how
did they do that we don't know and so
there's just there is a lot of mystery
and so you know in you talking about the
mystery schools you know i'm not well
versed in that but there's like isis's
mystery school hathor's mystery school
right there's there's all the different
they had they had they were masters of
the mind i mean they could manifest
incredibly and they were absolute
masters did you learn about them what
was it about the mystery schools that
you learned when you traced it all the
way back all of the teachings like the
fact that we create our reality and the
and the
that the mind is projecting absolutely
everything and so the mind is creating
everything and so that was really the
biggest thing i mean basically it's the
all the principles of the secret i mean
it's just the law of the mind and it's
the way that everything works and
subconscious mind and the conscious mind
and and thought and
and so
all of all of those things
which came from
the mystery schools there was an order
where i
it's called the rose cross order in
europe and i landed upon that order when
i was going back in time and that order
took me to all of these incredible
people like francis bacon and all these
victor hugo and all of these men who
knew all of this
yeah and isaac newton who was a part of
this secret order and the reason it was
secret was because you were you were
executed if you tried to empower people
then and so they worked they worked in
secret but all of their teachings came
from the ancient mystery schools
and so
i studied these teachings of the rose
cross order um i i've done like
something like 22 degrees so i've
studied those over the
over the years since the secret
and um and you know it's it's incredible
because you learn all about
oh just everything um all about the
physicality the cycles the
karma the law of karma and all of the
things that you learn
i saw that you had the um the book by
the three and this year it's the
kebaleon
and so you learn all of those things the
law of vibration the law of gender and
all of those kinds of things and
and so i learned all of those things and
then many spiritual things and learn one
of the spiritual things i learned was
how to pop clouds and you think well why
do you need to pop clouds well because
it shows you
the power of the mind and the focus of
the mind and so that's in a degree
like years into a degree i think that
was like the
something like the 11th degree and i
thought well can i do this but you know
you've taken all of the steps to the to
that path and it's just understanding
that everything is consciousness and and
that cloud is not all that way away from
me
and so i
we were taught to like put ourselves in
the middle of the cloud and blow it
away and so i would project myself into
the middle of the cloud and i would feel
the cold of the cloud all around me and
then i would just blow it away and i
would like open my eyes and i would say
oh
like whole lot of the cloud has gone i'd
close my eyes again and i just blow
again and the cloud is completely gone
and so they did that so that you can
understand the power of the mind that
all of this is the mind and we have the
power to be able to
do things like that
so in the three initiates the the whole
thing is that all is the mind right
right always in the mind yeah
um
so how many degrees are there 33 is this
mason masonry it's not it's not the
freemasons no
it's uh no it's completely different
from the freemasons yeah
so it's like nobody's ever heard of this
order it's weird well no not so much
yeah not so much in the united states i
think more in in europe um because the
order has
it has
well at the moment you know it's in the
canary islands so
um
but the teachings are translated and you
know and you get
you get pamphlets and you learn
everything about
the world the duality of the world
the mind um
karma the body you come to understand
that the body is a perfect mirror of the
solar system and each organ is reflected
in the solar system
and and
that uh
as within so without as above so below
and so all of those things you're just
learning and seeing those things and
it's just all revealed to you very
precisely and exactly
um
yeah
very exact and these teachings have been
passed on through hundreds of years
um
and preserved
uh
for people you know who are ready for
you know to learn about that kind of
thing you learn all about vibration
and sounds and om and
you know the the
what what you can even do with with the
sound
you know how how you can use that
um i don't do any of those things
anymore um i i i did i loved it all the
arms the raws the mars the
i loved all love doing all of those
things and understanding like they tell
you the lost word and all of these
incredible things but
um
and i don't i mean i have all of that i
guess so
i've i've absorbed all of that and uh
and it's it's all fantastic and with
without a doubt it has helped me on my
journey but i don't i'm not kind of
seeking out that kind of thing anymore
because i feel that i've just found
all that i needed to find well what i
would i keep hearing is in in all of
these stories that i'm so grateful
you're sharing they're so interesting
is that you
have proven over and over and over in
different ways how powerful the mind is
and that that might be kind of what i'm
feeling for even myself or maybe someone
else might need to hear is like just try
things just see what you can do and so
since you've proven to yourself through
these modalities and these techniques
and these skills
uh and these ancient tradition
traditions that that you have this power
so it's not a matter of having to
practice it you use it when you need it
that's true that's absolutely true and
my life is so um
[Music]
smooth
that
uh
and also is so smooth but also i'm so
allowing of everything
now i'm just like so if something
happens that normally
i would think oh i don't want that or i
want to change that i don't want to
change it i just know that everything is
unfolding perfectly and so if something
occurs that is maybe not what i want
then i just i just really release that i
release that feeling that i don't
want it and uh and then it changes
that's the thing the only reason
something stays the same is because of
our
resistance yes
exactly exactly that i'm so good at the
death grip too i practiced it for 27
years
fundamentally then
in all of this learning all of this
exposure to these traditions and these
in history
why is it hidden
look i used to ask that question all the
time of the imperative um
i would say to him that you know all of
these secrets they should be released
into the world
people should know these things and he
would he would say to me
you know people aren't ready
and um they're not ready to hear these
things and
and he said anybody who's ready will be
led to these things so in other words
when
the student is ready the teacher will
appear
and right and you've just got to be
sort of on that frequency and
um and so i i remember that i used to
think
uh
um the imperator he would have ma you
know masters appear and i'd be like i
want a master to appear
i want a master to appear and um
and so
he would say to me there's only one
master
yes
yes
and the master is within you there's
only one and the master is within you
and and so and now i see that
i see all of the things that he used to
say to me and that all of them
made um
they were cut some of them were
frustrating at the time
i was gonna say that i was gonna isn't
it always frustratingly simple the
advice and you're like
that's not helping right now
that's right and there were things that
i discovered like i don't know ten years
later and i would say to him i've just
had this realization
and i would explain it and he would say
yes you are correct and i was like
why would it help me a lot if you told
me that 10 years ago you know
but he i wouldn't have been able to hear
it
you know you you just
you can only
you can only like consciousness is
expanding and and and so you can only
hear what you're ready to hear
but i want to say to everybody there is
so much for you to hear
there's so much for you to see
and just to just like keep opening
yourself to the possibility
that
there is nothing is the way that it
appears to be
um the heels of the original inspiration
and story about the
insatiable
drive to learn and absorb after reading
that book which i'm so glad i heard
the story about your daughter giving you
the book because i wondered when i
re-watched the secret the other night
because i was like i should buff up and
re-watch a secret and how the the
post-it on the book said um mama i you
need this what was it mama thankful that
will help
help and so i'm glad i heard the story
but
what is it now and i'm
exaggerating in my words but i'm using
it as an analogy what keeps you up at
night now
just being
just being that is like and it's such a
dud answer because it's not very
exciting you know
so it's kind of no mind you know just
letting the mind
and just being and what one thing that i
found was the secret was so
extraordinary
in helping me
use the mind for what's meant to be used
for which is to create what we want
and so my thoughts became positive and i
really became very aware of negative
thoughts and i wouldn't allow them to
roost on me so my life really became
incredible in every area of my life
because all of my thoughts were really
positive and i would pick people up when
they would say something i'd be like
don't say that
change what you're saying you know
cancel that out say something else say
what you want not what you don't want
um
and so
and so
my life was really really incredible the
difference now is so that so the secret
helped me so much
because it helped me master the mind in
that way
and now
the mind does not have control
it doesn't have control
and so now i have
exist with this beautiful happiness
and just use the mind when i need the
mind like to talk to you today and
um
and just use the mind when it's
necessary but the mind
is not nearly as strong doesn't have the
strength to kind of rise up and take
over and take me down a rabbit hole with
some story it's created and then have me
buy into that story and believe it and
then have me suffer because of that
story
it doesn't have that kind of power over
me anymore and it was just a progression
first of all the secret and then
so aware of your thoughts
you know just becoming aware and aware
of how you're feeling because feelings
and thoughts of both the mind
is that um is that what by the way i got
the greatest secret and this book it
it's heavy like really heavy
is it the gold i'm wondering if it's
actually real gold because it's so heavy
but is that is that the greatest secret
to to release the mind that there is
absolutely it's just it is that shows
you the way it is heavy and i think it's
the paper and it's beautiful and it's
thick and it's thick too
um
uh
yeah to release the mind it's really
to it's it continues on from the secret
because the secret shows you how to use
the mind for what you want in your life
what the greatest secret does it shows
you how to release the mind so it can't
beat us up
torturous you know sabotage our life and
create negativity and
you know with negative thoughts negative
feelings torture us with negative
feelings
uh
you know getting angry over things and
all of that and and and keep creating
all those circumstances out in the world
that are triggers
so that the emotions of rising us so
it's to be free of all of the suffering
um so yeah that's really what what it is
and when you remove all of those those
things of the mind then what is left is
the most exquisite
happiness that is unshakable will not
move even in
an urgent situation you know if an
urgent situation arises that happiness
is there but if an urgent situation
arises
you know
you will
be led to do exactly the right thing
you will be guided to do exactly the
right thing whereas the mind will be
what will i do
you know
instead you will
you are just kind of being placed
everywhere perfectly
in life way better than you could ever
do yourself
isn't that the truth isn't it that's the
truth
thank you so much for your
you know
15 years of guiding us and and exposing
the secret and giving us all tools to
happiness and
having the things that we really want in
life and recognizing at the end of the
day our true innate power
well thank you thank you so much for
having me is just
a delight to talk to you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button